lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver
si podemos entender la idea de un fondo
de cobertura de un poco mejor estos
tienden a ser un poco misteriosos y en
ocasiones son vistos de manera negativa
porque algunos fondos de cobertura si
efectúan algunos asuntos extraños y
secretos en el mercado y la gente pues
con todo derecho sospecha verdad así que
es bueno la diferencia real entre un
fondo de cobertura y tipos de fondos
mutualistas en los que acabamos de
conversar es que estos no son regulados
por la comisión de valores de los
estados unidos ok y porque no son
regulados no pueden darse y no pueden
anunciarse a sí mismos ok no pueden
anunciarse por eso cuando ves algunos
algunos programas financieros o revistas
de finanzas no verás comerciales para
fondos de cobertura los fondos
mutualistas están en todos lados los
anuncian de izquierda a derecha de los
fondos de cobertura en definitivamente
en definitiva no son nombres familiares
nadie nadie incluso muy pocas personas
saben cuáles son esos fondos de
cobertura es por eso por esto es que no
pueden
el mercado técnico que no importa qué
tan bueno sea el récord del fondo no
importa no pueden anunciarse ok y
tampoco pueden tomar dinero del público
no pueden tomar dinero del público ok
entonces en general para poder invertir
en un fondo de cobertura tienes que ser
un inversionista acreditado lo que
significa que tenga cierto valor tenga
ciertos ingresos o una educación que
puedas comprobar que tiene cierto nivel
de sofisticación para para invertir y
que no vas a necesitar a la secc para
cubrirte la espalda la sé que es la la
comisión de valores
entonces las regulaciones la diferencia
clave verdad digamos la diferencia es
como son motivados los gerentes ok en el
mundo de los fondos mutualistas los
gerentes obtienen un porcentaje de los
bienes ok entonces poner el gerente de
un fondo mutualista más grande significa
mejor
mientras más su gerenciamiento más
dinero
más van a seguir anunciándose ellos no
obtienen una porción de las ganancias
entonces realmente no existe mucha
motivación para aquellos que intenten
realmente ganarse el mercado ok porque
si no le ganan al mercado un año
entonces de repente ellos ya saben su
fondo se disminuirá y entonces realmente
obtienen una cuota por el tamaño del
fondo y un fondo de cobertura usualmente
la implicación es que el fondo de
cobertura será manejado activamente
entonces una cuota de gerenciamiento
mayor ok
una cuota de género de gerenciamiento
mayor
en vez del 1% en realidad es es mucho
más grande digamos los fondos de
cobertura tienen 1 a 2 por ciento de de
cuota de gerenciamiento en ocasiones
incluso mayores que eso pero la
diferencia aún mayor es aquí donde los
fondos de cobertura son son distintos a
los mutualistas tradicionales es que la
gerencia o el socio general obtiene un
porcentaje mucho mayor entonces el
gerente de una de un fondo de cobertura
o de la compañía
la tarifa tiende a ser alrededor del 20
por ciento de las ganancias para los
en ocasiones es menor en ocasiones es
mayor verdad algunos fondos de cobertura
muy exitosos obtienen 25-30 o incluso un
porcentaje mucho mayor que esto entonces
ya establecido esto en el próximo vídeo
voy a hacer una diferencia ligera en
algunas mecánicas respecto a los fondos
de cobertura y luego para los
mutualistas